على خط امداد استراتيجي بين منطقه سيدنيت
سكولوجانس في اقليم جمباز تقع باخ موت
وتخوض القوه الروسيه هجمات لدخول المدينه
من ضاحيتها الجنوبيه ومن المناطق الشرقيه
للمدينه الصناعيه ومن شان السيطره عليها
بنحوسيه منطلقا للتقدم نحو مدينتين اكبر
وهما اكرام تورس والسلوفيا المعركه الاكبر
تقع في بلده سوليدر غير بعيد عن بخموت
وتضع القوات الاوكرانيه في موضع الحرج ذلك
ان التلال المرتفع في سوليدار تشرف على كل
طرق الامداد وخطوط الاتصال بما يتسهل
وتطبيق من الشمال وتعطيل خطوط التواصل
الاوكرانيه وفق مسؤولين اوكرانيين قصفت
البلده ست و80 مره بالمدفعيه في اربع و
عشرين ساعه وقال الرئيس الاوكراني انه لا
حوائط قائمه في سوليدار وان الارض مغطاه
بشده الروسي فيها وقد تكمله اهميه المنطقه
وفقاء
مؤسسين مجموعه في انفاق التعدين الغ
والممتده تحت الارض والتي يمكنها ان تتسع
للجنود او الدبابات
[موسيقى]